[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de 7,8 le débat nous
parlerons ce soir de consommation avec
cette question comment rééquilibrer la
fréquentation entre les centres villes
et les grands ensembles des périphéries
un mot résume le problème
désertification c'est celle des
centre-villes bien sûr dont il est
question le taux de vacance commercial
est passé de 2 6% à plus de 10% en une
quinzaine d'années en france ce
plusieurs rapports gouvernementaux sont
sortis pour tenter de remédier à cette
situation le plus récent étant celui
commandé à l'automne par la secrétaire
d'état au commerce martine pinville dans
ce contexte difficile de ne pas se poser
la question de l'utilité de nouveaux
centres commerciaux
on évoquera le cas du futur ensemble
open sky en construction à plaisir les
consommateurs sont ils assez nombreux
pour ses différents pôles commerciaux
peut-on mieux les aiguiller avec nous
pour en débattre ce soir joséphine
coleman ce berger maire les républicains
de plaisir et fabienne 15 may ou
présidente de l'union des commerçants et
artisans de maurepas et gérante d'une
boutique dans le centre ville de
maurepas bonsoir à toutes les deux
fabienne 15 mai lieu je me tourne
d'abord vers vous aujourd'hui à quoi
ressemble le centre-ville de maurepas
alors je dirais qu'il est de plus en
plus désert essentiellement et surtout
le week-end le marché amène une
attractivité du chalon mais ensuite
l'après midi
les revenus sont franchement déserte par
contre on s'aperçoit que le chaland les
clients sont au tour du centre ville
dans les centres commerciaux
alors justement à la situation pourtant
le département continue d'augmenter son
offre en matière de centres commerciaux
le futur espace de plaisir sera baptisé
open sky
donc là on parle de 32 mille mètres
carrés 35 boutiques un restaurant un
espace cinéma est-ce que ça répond à un
véritable besoin je vais dire oui je
vais vous dire oui tout d'abord parce
que au départ c'était et ça l'est encore
une friche une friche en plein centre
ville donc on ne pouvait pas laisser les
c'est sous cette forme là et puis oui
parce que d'abord les cinémas vous venez
d'évoquer vous même c'est une véritable
attente et une enquête d'ailleurs qui a
été fait et un diagnostic a été fait sur
l'ensemble du département pour dire
qu'aujourd'hui il y avait encore un
manque au niveau des salles de cinéma
donc à ce niveau là je sais qu'il ya une
véritable attente et un besoin non
seulement une attente
et puis en ce qui concerne le centre
commercial
alors outre le fait bien sûr d'aménager
cette friche qui est véritablement un
désert et puis quelque chose de très
très vilain serre mais habitant
voilà parlait aussi de problèmes
d'insécurité il y avait voilà c'est
nécessaire site est nécessaire mais ce
qui est important et vous avez raison de
le dire puisque vous le disiez en
préambule je crois qu'il faut réfléchir
à l équilibre entre les commerces de
proximité et les centres commerciaux on
a la chance je dirais plaisir d'avoir
tout cet espace qui est un espace de
centre commercial que beaucoup de gens
connaissent bien sûr et puis nous avons
une ville qui est très éclaté en
quartier avec dans les différents
quartiers des commerces de proximité et
nous souhaitons bien sûr et nous avons
déjà démarré il ya deux ans toute une
démarche pour maintenir ces commerces de
proximité voire même les développer
puisque nous avons actuellement des
choses qui sont en cours on en parlera
juste après alors justement parle d'
équilibre fabienne kazmi ou est-ce que
votre baisse de fréquentation dans le
centre-ville de maurepas on peut
l'imputer à ses centres commerciaux
il y en a quand même beaucoup dans le
département les clayes-sous-bois alpha
part que one nation opensky à saint
quentin on à l'espace saint quentin oui
voilà
candide ou alors je pense
qu'effectivement si c'est en partie une
responsabilité effectivement des centres
commerciaux mais pas que cela
je pense que il y à aussi de la part de
la clientèle un changement d'habitude
nous avons les sites internet entre
autres qui qui font des crises et
concurrence au centre de ramallah tout à
fait donc il ya une mutation ça c'est
clair du commerce et des habitudes des
clients
et c'est vrai qu'il faut trouver
l'équilibré et qui est pas facile parce
que nous ne sommes pas égaux
même par rapport à la communication et à
dire que ces grandes enseignes ont les
moyens de communiquer compagne les
petits artisans commerçants
donc c'est un peu le pot de terre contre
le pot de fer et puis effectivement vu
la baisse de clientèle le chiffre
d'affaires diminue donc un problème
aussi pour investir pour éventuellement
valoriser les magasins et de pouvoir
attirer aussi les clients
donc effectivement il faut trouver un
équilibre et qui est pas évident à
trouver aujourd'hui il ya un problème
aussi de stationnement les clients
aujourd'hui désir carrément rentrer dans
le magasin donc en fonction
effectivement de l'urbanisation
il ya les problèmes qui sont la pose est
comment réhabiliter certains centres
villes pour qu'il soit d'accès facile et
que les gens aient envie de 10 venir et
c'est un centre commercial le centre
ville on n'a pas le choix comme dans les
grands centres commerciaux
donc il faut que les clients et
l'intérêt de devenir et pour ça il faut
faciliter aussi l'entrée de ville par
une bonne signalétique nous est indiqué
par des pictogrammes les magasins qui
cite reparlera juste après des moyens de
redynamiser le centre ville
alors madame le maire vous qui justement
avait vu sur les centres commerciaux et
les petits commerces de plaisir comment
vous gérez cet équilibre alors déjà pour
est pour moi ce que vous disiez je suis
d'accord avec vous en grande partie
c'est que c'est vrai que les chalands
ont changé leur mode de fonctionnement
pour travailler avec les centres
commerciaux je me suis rendu compte et
ils nous l'ont dit qu'aujourd'hui il ne
souhaitait plus vraiment passé des
heures dans les centres commerciaux
donc il ya un retour aussi à la
proximité est un mode de fonctionnement
différent dans les centres commerciaux
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui ils sont
conscients de cela ils vont le modifier
et pour répondre à votre question
eh bien il est important que les villes
soient porteuses de un projet autour du
commerce de proximité
les grandes enseignes n'ont pas besoin
de nous ils ont besoin nous pour
s'installer pour se positionner
il est important de travailler avec eux
parce que moi je ne les laisse pas
s'installer si on n'a pas réfléchi au
parking ça c'est une évidence mais aussi
aux voiries aux circulations douces aux
espaces verts
donc tout ça c'est pas quelque chose
qu'ils font de leur côté ils le font
avec nous mais en parallèle il faut que
nous soyons porteur d'un accompagnement
auprès des commerces de proximité sur ce
que nous avons fait à plaisir depuis
deux ans nous nous sommes rapprochés des
commerces de proximité
nous avons mis en place un manager de
ville en conventionnement avec la
chambre de commerce qui aujourd'hui à
monter avec les commerçants une
association qui commence cette énergie
et non pas cette bataille contre 8 les
centres commerciaux mais un
accompagnement et une complémentarité
parce que c'est
vous disiez le pot de fer contre le pot
de terre en réalité les centres
commerciaux leur représentation bon il
ya des lobbys j'aime c'est ça que les
petits commerçants sont pas réunies dont
il ya cette problématique là de les
réunir pour qu'ils aient voix au
chapitre en tout à fait y en plus il
manque de temps puisque ils n'ont pas
toute une série de personnes autour pour
s'occuper de ce genre de chose comme 6
et madame à la raison sur la
communication sur se faire connaître
donc nous au niveau de la collectivité
je crois qu'on a notre rôle à jouer
si on le souhaite je pense
qu'effectivement il faut qu'il y ait une
volonté politique pour accompagner le
commerce de proximité pour qu'ils
puissent est valorisée je pense qu'on
peut faire la différence entre les
grandes enseignes et la spécifité
individuelle de chaque commerçant avec
sa personnalité son artisanat son savoir
faire
ce qui je dirais rayonne dans les pays
étrangers et le bien être et le savoir
vivre à la française
et je pense que ça il faut effectivement
conserver cela pour qu'on soit pas après
dans un village des vieux métiers dias
entend et qu'on fasse figure de
figurants dans des boutiques factice
donc alors justement le rapport remis au
gouvernement cet automne pointe en avant
le fait qu'il faut moderniser ses
centres villes notamment les mettre au
numérique
inventer des nouvelles manières de deux
pas de vendre en fait tout simplement
cessé centre-ville qui sont comme des
centres commerciaux
oui je pense qu'effectivement il faut se
déguiser entre guillemets comme un
centre commercial c'est reprendre
effectivement ce qui fonctionne et
pourquoi ça fonctionne je pense
qu'effectivement il ya des modèles à
peut-être retranscrire dans notre centre
ville pour qu'ils puissent effectivement
attiré
et mettre l'accent sur la différence
effectivement comme vous disiez les gens
n'ont pas forcément envie de perdre du
temps et que le centre ville offre
justement du temps on en a une en voilà
et que là du coup sûr une petite zone on
puisse trouver des commerçants bouche
rapidement facilement et est alors
justement open sky dans le dans le
dossier dans la maquette ça ressemble
presque un centre ville parce que déjà
open sky s'est amassée à ciel ouvert
donc vous avez voulu un peu recréer
cette ambiance est d'ailleurs l'espace
saint quentin et la galerie marchande
marche bien là parce qu'on dirait en
centre-ville et c'est ce qui plaît aux
gens exactement c'est à dire retrouver
des lieux de vie si ce que l'on demande
aujourd'hui c'est à dire pour voir bien
sûr se garer à proximité voire à
l'intérieur mais ensuite pouvoir
déambuler et avoir cette sensation de
l'extérieur qui n'est pas une sensation
puisque dans le cadre un peu des scans y
en ait véritablement 2 donc ça c'est
quelque chose que nous avons souhaité
avec la compagnie de phalsbourg pour
pouvoir réfléchir dans ce sens là et
nous avons la chance d'avoir nous ce
centre au centre ville donc on veut un
maillage complet entre entre le centre
ville les habitants qui sont vraiment de
l'autre côté du rond-point ou de l'autre
côté de la rue ou même derrière
complètement et j'ai demandé également
que nous fassions des boutiques à
l'arrière de ce bâtiment pour s'ouvrir
sur le quartier qui est derrière pour
justement ne pas tourner le dos et puis
quand vous évoquiez tout à l'heure je
dirais cet équilibre quand l'on devait
trouver au niveau des centres villes ce
qui est important de savoir c'est que
nous avons aussi nous les maires la
responsabilité de réfléchir au centre
ville ils ont plus de 40 ans d'existence
aujourd'hui pour la plupart voire au
delà quand ils sont historiques et je
dirais dans leur aménagement
il faut je pense véritablement pensé à
deir qualification de centre ville
sur les quinze à vingt années pour
pouvoir accompagner ces transformations
et dans les développements immobiliers
je crois qu'il est important aussi de
penser à demander à nos promoteurs
d'instaurer et d'installer des cellules
en bas d'immeuble
pour pouvoir créer des centres afpa des
centres mais des boutiques de proximité
comme vous le disiez boulangerie etc
je crois que c'est fondamental si on ne
pense pas à ça on fait petit à petit un
désert effectivement commercial et quand
une ville et étendu comme sont toutes
nos villes ici en région parisienne il
faut véritablement que dans chaque
quartier on y trouve au moins ce que
l'on a besoin pour le pour le quotidien
et ça c'est fondamental vous idée pour
le centre-ville de maurepas vous aviez
parlé de mettre de la musique à plaisir
ils ont pensé à une patinoire alors à
l'uqam à quoi vous allez handicap
surtout en fait la stratégie que j'ai
voulu mettre en oeuvre cette année c'est
que les habitants auraient affectionne
leur centre ville pour dire
effectivement le centre ville il y a une
vie s'y passe des choses donc on a mis
plusieurs actions autour plutôt
culturels autour d'eux des enfants et
pour amener les parents et les grands
parents pour qu'ils redécouvrent leur
centre ville parce que je me suis fait
une réflexion pas la réflexion a été que
beaucoup de gens même qui habitait
centre ville ne fréquentais même pas le
centre-ville aller faire leurs courses à
auchan ou même d'autres n'allait même
pas alors comment on fait pour lui alors
oui alors c'est bien là la quelques mois
c'est la bière le problème je pense
qu'effectivement une fois de la
communication il fait effectivement que
le
le magazine de la ville de maurepas
servent de supports de communication
pour soutenir nos actions cercle compte
là on a fait une animation pour noël que
l'on n'est pas uniquement un timbre
poste en terme de communication quand on
fait des animations dans le centre ville
on a vraiment besoin de ce soutien
voilà pour vraiment dire on est là on
existe les commerçants font des choses
bougent désir que leurs clients
reviennent ray affectionne leur centre
ville et ils viennent au moins une fois
dans la semaine faire au moins leurs
courses 1 merci un mot de conclusion
chacune
madame le maire de plaisir un mot de
conclusion
écoutez on essaye de trouver
véritablement une osmose entre le centre
ville les quartiers et le centre
commercial par une étude que nous avons
enclenchée
il y a deux ans et qui va être présenté
aux plaisirs mois au mois de février
pour justement maintenir cet équilibre
dont on parlait en préambule et c'est
fondamental les petits commerces doivent
vivre absolument ils ont besoin des
mères phalène 15000 vous allez être
d'accord là-dessus vêtements de
conclusion le soleil brille pour tout le
monde
très bien merci à vous d'avoir participé
à cette émission se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau débat
[Musique]